Hey Youtubers It's Charlie they dropped the official
Jessica Jones trailer David Tennant is creeptastic
he's totally going to make you cry and not
in the Star Wars Way the funny thing the about
that is the David Tennant was actually part
of Star Wars if you ever watched the clone
wars he was the droid on the Jedi ship the
funny thing about the ship is that it traveled
all over space for eons so he got to be immortal
during doctor who and he got to be immortal
during Star Wars obviously not going to be
immortal in marvel's universe but still very
powerful the trailer pretty much answers exactly
where the story picks up it's pretty much
on par with the alias comic that she debuted
and brought Brian Michael Bendis' comic working
as a private investigator at her own business
alias investigations that the name of her
business that's the the trailer opens with
her his busting a random head that's how she
earns money mostly for booze that she says
it but it's kind of opposed adventure series
and that she's already trying to be a superhero
it went terribly she ran afoul the purple
man and he totally after up and print presumably
she has escaped and now he's coming back to
town just trying to put her life back together
somewhat unsuccessfully now the he's come
back this is what Kirby called action the
other big thing is that she looks like she's
just meeting Luke Cage for the first time
this bar the door and it looks like he's the
bartender it's probably the bar that we see
in all these promos they been posting and
based on the conversation it sounds like Luke
Cage either doesn't have his powers yet or
he is hiding them from her just because he's
like seems to me like being a superhero puts
a target on your back reselling her lay low
but she is using her powers so you don't maybe
we'll get to see Luke Cage get his origin
story before his own series this is mostly
going to follow Jessica Jones bouquets is
just a big part of it that they're always
got changed a few minor things about the story
just to make it like out like a tighter narrative
so hellcat here this is hellcat by the way
from the comics probably not to get a costume
during the series during the series hellcat
is a broadcaster so it looks like she's been
a little bit more successful at putting her
life back together the Jessica Jones has the
whole metaphor the series is that you know
Jessica Jones is very tough but mentally she
is not so the idea is the purple man gives
this big called action she defeats them near
his like the big boss of the series and she
becomes mentally tough as well as physically
tough if you wanted to start making ponds
you could say she needs to grow some thick-skinned
that would definitely be a Luke Cage reference
but they are in Hells kitchen and I know a
lot of you are asking if they name dropped
daredevil were she's like the devil did this
she's not talking about the Devil of Hell's
kitchen she's calling the purple man the devil
and just talk about David Tennant I feel like
they did the right thing in not showing his
face like he's scarier when you don't see
his face it's a metaphor for how his powers
work like Jessica Jones even though she hasn't
been in proximity to him for a long time the
pheromones that he exudes like that the way
his power works it lives in your bloodstream
like it doesn't just go away immediately the
minute he walks away it's kinda like a biological
toxin there like really really powerful pheromones
so the longer you're in proximity to him the
longer the effect will last after he leaves
so yes she does have like super bad PTSD but
there's also price of the lingering effect
of his pheromones in her bloodstream in the
trailer she talks about you know like you
don't know the things he made me do he just
makes her commit crimes using her superpowers
and I know this place the gonna be some confusion
about this till the first episode but she
can't fly she's jumping like Golden age Superman
your leap tall buildings with a single bound
may moment maybe not quite that I she couldn't
jump all the way to the top of the avengers
tower and in the event just Howard does exist
in this series will probably see like way
off in the distance but that's actually one
thing that they also probably commit to them
down the series regular tuner powers down
to soul but she can't fly and it also price
to down the role of the avengers know in the
alias comic she had previously tried to become
a member of the avengers unsuccessfully she
been friends with all the A-list Avengers
I'm guessing that's not the case in the TV
series not the avengers will be there like
shall know about them when she talks about
her time trying to be a superhero like trying
to use her powers for good it's probably more
like and that the daredevil contexts something
much more local to where she grew up you have
to remember that these are street-level heroes
so so largely they're going to be self-contained
to the boroughs of New York for their first
series pickup I think once we get the defenders
team up in their sphere of influence will
slowly grow innovatively or maybe season to
season three of each of the shows and for
those that are wondering they haven't confirmed
that yet they haven't confirmed Jessica Jones
season two but I totally think were gonna
see five seasons of all these TV shows at
least as long as the actors want to keep making
them is it's not a money issue I know you
guys are all getting high now this is all
dropping November 20 so I'm going to try and
do is many videos when it drops is possible
it will probably end up being like four or
five separate videos for all the episodes
in the maybe like a couple bonus videos on
top of that so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll be sure to do a giveaway whenever
it starts to if you guys are hype already
let me just like dump some gasoline on the
flames here so Carrie Ann Moss who appears
in the trailer is playing Jeryn Hogarth from
the comics that is someone who works for iron
fists father so that is the connection to
iron fist that they haven't cast that actor
yet but you can kinda see how they're weaving
in all these Netflix series together as Jessica
Jones episode one picks up the Devil of Hell's
kitchen has been slowly being that shipped
out of all the criminals in the neighborhood
so she slowly learns about him and she runs
into Jaron Hogarth who is the lawyer for iron
fists family in the context of the comics
iron fist is kind of like the Bruce Wayne
to the outsiders like Bruce Wayne funds a
lot of superhero teams iron fist funds the
defenders because the super rich so just because
we have iron fist things you will see Easter
eggs for iron fist but they haven't cast the
actor yet so you won't actually see an iron
fist person or they might refer to Wendell
Rand or Rand industries Wendell Rand is the
any rants father Wendell actually tried to
become the first iron fist and fell in love
with the person who became iron fist mother
so iron fist was born into mysticism money
and martial arts as we watch the series we
can we can totally take everything apart for
all the strings of the other Netflix series
but we might see an actual full-blown cameo
from daredevil so white as way for more Netflix
stuff I'm I'm catching up with got them I
have a flash arrow Q&A there's actually a
gorilla Grodd video that I'm really excited
to make Danielle Panabaker and Andrew Kreisberg
of the executive producer the flash was talking
about Grodd in this King Kong context with
Caitlin snow so, to make a King Kong Grodd
video next while you guys wait for everything
to post you can click here for all my Jessica
Jones trailer videos and you can click here
to catch up with the flash this week, thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five and I'll see you guys tonight!